[Music]
each year after the harvest
the people of thieves held a celebration
of the dead
called the beautiful festival of the
valley
they carried statues of thebes three
main gods in a grand procession
out of karnak temple east of the river
they crossed the nile on ceremonial
boats following the sun's journey from
the east bank
the land of the living to the west the
land of the dead
[Music]
the procession ended at the tombs and
temples on the west bank
where people had laid offerings
including pots of food
at the graves of the deceased
the ritual ensured the dead had
provisions for eternity
these pots mean a tomb should be very
close
i think it is a fragment maybe
maybe muhammad muhammad are you seeing
something else
you wish he wash him
but i don't sing maybe not no muhammad
i think i am right you are right
yes we have a great
great news it's a face
so it's imperial for a coffin
the roughly carved casket appears to be
buried in a miniature tomb
this is clearly no king but it's a vital
clue that he might be near
my happiness will be completed belonging
to 17 dynasties
and archaeology i am not sure about
anything i don't trust anything
until i have it in my hand
if the burial does predate ammon hotep
the first
it proves was a cemetery by the time he
died
so he could be buried here but there's
no way to tell
until this coffin is out of the ground
[Music]
you